[Music]
any rumor of a russian advance and
hurriedly formed roadblocks suddenly
appear
volunteers and reservists springing into
action
the defense of kiev is taking on a
character of its own a character of
collective responsibility with vast
swathes of society taking part
a short distance from this checkpoint
two vehicles have been placed across the
road into the centre of kiev
volunteers filling sandbags and building
the defenses
action is what is needed now they say
not words
we're waiting
when you
we're waiting when you wake up
then you understand
from your sanctions where is birzowski
where is nemtsov do you know where is
these people
who guilty
so
you will be next
people on the street who don't want to
fight are either attempting to leave or
heading for bomb shelters
but there are huge numbers of militias
forming they're everywhere guns in hand
prepared to die fighting the russians
the country's president is calling for
everyone and indeed anyone to take up
arms
all those who can return to ukraine come
back to defend ukraine
and then we will have a lot of work to
rebuild it
all those who can defend ukraine abroad
do it purposefully unitedly and
continuously
all friends of ukraine who want to join
the defense come we will give you
weapons
we had italian
the city is remarkably quiet eerily so
few people probably believe that kiev
would still be held by the government
for this length of time
but there is always nightly violence
a rocket struck this apartment block in
the early hours of saturday
a terrifying explosion filmed outside
and inside
terrifying the population is certainly
its aim
in train stations and in the metro
people find shelter either prepared to
stay or waiting for a train away from
kiev
amongst them a group of university
students ordered home by their parents
yeah maybe russia wasn't as har as big
as what everyone thought it was yeah
yeah they thought it just could do it in
day or two but our army is too strong
and with the help of
european community and usa i think
we can do it
a key to any success in the defense of
kiev will be holding the eight major
bridges that link the east and west of
the city that or destroy them
ukraine and russia both know this
well the security services here are now
absolutely convinced that russian
special forces and what they call fifth
columnists are trying to cross into the
center of kiev using the bridges that
are very much the lifeblood
of the city they've said that they will
use lethal force on anyone attempting to
cross uh the british now some will
probably try but they've also sort of
made an appeal that it's so critical now
that everyone needs to pull together and
do as they're told
concerns about the infiltration of the
city means that freedom of movement is
getting harder a curfew is now in place
until monday with no exceptions
soldiers will continue anyone on the
street the russian spy
for many people this is likely to be a
long and perhaps terrifying weekend mr
ramsay sky news kiev